au départ quand on est rentré sur ce
groupe on a commencé à observer tout
doucement
j'ai essayé de remonter le plus loin
possible dans la seconde pour pouvoir me
faire une image et m'imprégner un petit
peu du genre de personnages qui faisait
ça on a vu des crânes des masques de
chat on a vu des des membres d'animaux
divers et variés avec le prix à côté
[Musique]
ici un berger allemand si vous voulez
les pâtes de gros toutou n'hésitez pas
on a pu voir qu'il y avait vraiment une
communauté de passionnés pour certains
et j'ai envie de dire je vais appeler ça
des trafiquants pour les autres
c'est une femme à la tête d'un trafic
très présente sur le groupe facebook à
ses yeux elle ne fait rien de grave elle
ne fait qu'à s'ouvrir sa passion
regardez moi je ne veux pas être comme
tout le monde et je ne suis pas comme
tout le monde j'ai une passion qui n'est
pas commune je ne collectionne pas des
cartes téléphoniques des timbres poste
ou des capsules de champagne
je collectionne des crânes des fœtus en
conservation liquide des choses qui
sortent du commun
les ossements ça c'est mon truc
hyper morbide d'abord bravo pour le
scoop du groupement parce que c'est une
super info mais ce sont des malades ces
gens-là c'est-à-dire que le les cadavres
d'animaux sont démembrés
disséqués dépossés c'est horrible et il
se les revendre comme trophées qui peut
dans sa tête être assez dérangé pour
faire ça il faut savoir que la
taxidermie on a le droit d'empailler des
animaux mais utilisez récupérer des
cadavres comme ça c'est strictement
interdit c'est honteux c'est franchement
alors pour se procurer ces animaux morts
mots de les récupère chez les
équarisseurs avant que les animaux ne
soient incinérés et même maxéistique
regardez
un cochon un mouton chien chat
enfin beaucoup chez un chat j'ai juste
vous montrer un petit échantillon parce
que tout n'est pas là chaque semaine
j'ai des rentrées et
je croule sous les corps voilà donc ça
c'est toutes mes rentrées d'hier là j'ai
un minion petit cavalier king charles là
un épagneul breton là en dessous
rottweiler
le pire c'est que ça peut arriver à vos
animaux de compagnie sans que vous
sachiez votre animal meurt vous savez
pas s'il est incinéré voilà et en fait
ces gens-là les récupèrent alors eux
leur argument c'est dire le chien est
mort enfin ça montre quand même la
manière dont ces gens-là considèrent les
animaux c'est-à-dire comme des objets et
c'est c'est justement chaque animal a un
prix en fonction de sa taille ou de sa
rareté regardez les prix des annonces
qu'ils passent sur les réseaux
plus on venait vers moi pour on me
montrant de l'intérêt
pour ce que je faisais pour mes
pratiques plus j'avais de la demande
donc à partir de là bah ouais mais j'ai
quand même investi de l'argent donc je
vais facturer mon travail un squelette
de chat en vrac donc ossement mélangé
avec le crâne je le faisais 80 euros
tous les prix affichés ne tiennent pas
compte de la réduction un masque de chat
tel que ceux que j'ai pu faire je le
facturer 40 euros
c'est franchement dérisoire
qui fait partie des rares journalistes
qui cherchent pas la lumière mais être
utile et j'ai quand même une question
est-ce que je sais pas c'est les galopa
cette femme du coup suite à ce sujet
elle va être arrêtée ou pas du tout à la
liste illégale récupérer des cadavres
d'animaux cette illégal et les acheter
et si tes clients en fait parce que elle
ok c'est catastrophique et le problème
c'est qu'il y a un business c'est si
elle le vend ça veut dire qu'il y a des
gens qui sont prêts
à avoir une amende alors elle aura pas
de peine de prison mais elle peut avoir
une amende il faut savoir que c'est très
réglementé la mort des animaux selon
leur peau etc et si par exemple vous
avez un animal de compagnie qui meurt si
vous jetez son cadavre c'est interdit
vous avez une amende de 3750 euros c'est
très réglementé c'est vrai qu'en fait on
n'a pas le droit de d'enterrer nos
chiens dans nos jardins c'est ça qui est
compliqué c'est pour ça qu'il faut à
chaque fois les laisser au vétérinaire
et c'est là qu'on se rend compte que
peut-être son chien se retrouve là sur
un site comme ça c'est c'est voilà c'est
vraiment il y a rien à dire les gens
deviennent totalement fous